[Music]
before I started to prepare this lecture
I was thinking you know when we play the
game and it turns out to be an end game
typically we don't have too much time
left on our clocks right like from our
tournament experiences and we have to
evaluate the position really really fast
and make certain decisions um from your
tournament practice have you ever had
that feeling that you look at your
opponent and you see that he knows
what's going on and he already has
something um in his mind how to place
his pieces he knows this or that
structure have you had that feeling
every so it's totally common and what is
the difference what do you think what is
the difference between uh the person who
doesn't really know what to do in that
position and just consumes all the time
that he has left on the clocks and the
person who
knows who already know knows what what
he's doing what are the difference what
are the main
difference that that person knows
certain structures to which he wants to
lead that position because it's all
about knowing certain positions in the
end game and certain um tools how to win
or how to draw B of that position so
today we're going to work on some
positions that can happen in the
tournament in in the tournament game
really easy that happened in the
tournament games um the positions that
will have certain rules how um you will
have to play to make a draw to win some
of them will even have the name like
this position that you see on the screen
uh which is called the
triangulation already when you hear that
name triangulation something pops up in
your mind like triangle like geometric
figure right so it means you will have
to move with your king most likely with
the King right look at this position um
like a triangle um what is the main goal
of the
triangle does anybody
know to
move so uh trying to like doing the
triangulation you passing the move to
your opponent basically uh you want to
get the same position but with the move
of your your opponent this is a very
basic um I would say very easy position
but when it happens in your in your
practice and you have like let's let's
say less than five minutes on your
clocks to finish the
game uh you have to do it really fast
and you have to be real professional in
these type of positions to win uh so do
you have any ideas what will be your
plan winning this position let's say uh
you're playing with
white how do you want to place your
pieces so we want to get the same
position right but with black to move
why do we want black to move in this
position who knows raise your
hands black move we can grab opposition
come for inance King C7 right then we'll
play King C5 and then we get to B6
square and win A6 Pawn so pretty easy uh
what are the king moves to
d8
King D6 King
C8 C7 King
B7 King D7 so pretty easy right this is
what we want to get we want black to
move but in this position we have to
move our King so um let's come up with
some uh idea how do we get to the same
position how do we um get to to this
position but uh with black to move C4
would be a yes King
C4 King d8 what if I play King C7 like
let's calculate really fast King C7 King
C5 and then we get to B6 so pretty
easy how do you continue with
white king D4 we can call it a long
opposition so the short opposition if
the king is on D6 that will be the short
position King on D4 it's a long position
so we still want to uh when black king
to move to C7 and play King C5 that's
basically the
goal what is our next
move King D5 exactly did we get what we
wanted easier right but in when you play
the game so when you listen to the
lecture it's it's really easy because uh
I give you the hint and All the Right
Moves already pop up in your mind but
when you play the game it's just you you
and your thoughts your know
so you have to pull out the right move
from your head and just make it so uh
now we we already know the continuation
so just real fast let's let's see how we
win here King to B6 King B8 take the
pawn and I hope everybody can win this
position so it's it's really easy so I
would say that was just a warming up one
of those positions that can happen in
the tournament practice and you should
know how to win real fast
this is another interesting position uh
have you ever had these type of
positions that you would think with
white you're winning for sure and your
opponent has to
resign black to move let you play with
black guys um your last chance to make a
draw but your opponent has a has a
knight um I guess you you already
understood like what what move you have
have to find where to place your king
here if you play like King F6 then what
happens King G8 and uh the pawn gets to
h8 what what are two moves that we're
choosing
from
correct does anybody know for sure where
to place your king it seems to be a very
absolutely easy
position can you explain me so tell me
the move that you want to make and
explain why you want to place the king
there here you go mhm so uh King F7 uh
Knight C7 King f8 so our goal is to keep
the king blocked in the corner because
if the king uh gets out of the corner
black loses right away um keeping the
king in the corner is Possible only by
two moves King F7 and King f8 so uh we
are reviewing right now King
F7 King
F7 Knight to C7 then the only move king
of eight
check again the only
move so this is pretty easy already
right but when you have to make that
right
move how do you come to that logic that
you have to play King of7 not even just
by
calculating how can you memorize it so
um next time you don't have to recall
that it will be in your mind already
you'll know how do you have um how do
you choose this
move remember this is a very easy hint
in order to make a draw you have to
place the King on the same color where
the Knight is very easy but not not
everybody knows that so for the future I
I think it's pretty interesting example
so let's see what happens if you move
King to f8 what is the
difference the same route of the
night Knight A6 look at this position we
don't have um f a square anymore we have
to take the Knight or move the king
somewhere and then white king gets out
of the corner again pretty easy but when
you don't have enough time on your
clocks and you have to make the decision
the chance to make a mistake if you
don't know can be high so um again let's
memorize it so when you get into this
position just place the King on the same
color of the square that um the Knight
is um another question will be what if
what if your king is already on the
white square here let's say if if our
King is on F7 already do you think we
can make a
draw we can't make a draw right because
if if the king is on F7 it's basically
impossible so we have to move the king
to f8 and then the king will be on the
opposite color with with a um Knight so
the only chance is you should be the
second not the first one who is on that
on the same color move the king to the
same color
another example from the real um
tournament
practice from from the Royal Tournament
game um let's evaluate the position what
do what do we see
here so what do we know about the point
end games let's start with
that um why why two move here I'm sorry
I didn't say uh whose move it is so we
know about the pawn end games that PA
end games is all about calculating when
you have the point end game uh you
should stop and just start calculating
by the way this is a very good tool to
develop your calculating uh calculative
abilities just if you want to train um
that part of the of the game it's
sometimes not necessarily when say in
solve puzzles but just put some um Point
end game and just calculate don't move
the pieces but calculate so in this end
game obviously white is much better
white has extra point on before pass
Pawn just the only uh question is how to
win this
position so we we want to move the king
to C4 obviously because we want to push
the pawn right but before we need to um
Force the black's King to move out of D5
in order to move the king to C4 so this
end game will be all about the
tempos because black has the chance to
make a draw in this
position
uh what happened in the game white
played
A4 and you would think it's a normal
move because you try to force your
opponent to move the king from D5 why
not but the idea is that try to save the
moves uh the pawn moves uh as long as
possible if you can move with the King
and force the opponent's king to step
back use
that here B made a mistake just right
away she moved the uh Pawn to A4 let's
see how the game developed King C4 it
seems everything goes well King E6 D5
there every Everybody his brother would
do this move right so King D4 we're
getting uh closer to
E5 King
D6 now what are I going to do
guys it's seems to be that we are much
closer to uh promoting the pawn to the
queen right seems like King King will
move to D7 and then we'll move to E5 how
to achieve
that so what are we doing now now we
have to move the pawns
right another question which point do
you
move okay we um how many squares do you
want to move
H hav figured that one out yet let's
let's calculate let's say we move H4
with we put the pawn H4 um black plays
H5 let me show you so
H4 say
H5 F3 right the only the only move that
we have left and
G6 did we get any
closer to
E5 let's play let's try to get breakr so
um the other thing if it happens to you
and you know that you made that mistake
uh don't sit there and think why did I
make that move like it's all bad just
you will do that later after the game
you will review your mistakes and you
will tell yourself well that was really
bad thing I did that but once you
dealing with that position just continue
to deal forget what you did in the past
don't think about that because sometimes
I get in too much like focus on those
mistakes like she made that A4 move
which was obviously mistake because she
didn't save that tempo for her um like
the winning move her Tempo to to get to
E5 still you have chances maybe black
will make a mistake maybe triangulation
will work um let's see how can we move
here King C4 the only move
right um maybe black can make a mistake
we don't know so the right move
obviously is King C7 trying to um keep
that
opposition where would you like to
move King
C3 if I play to uh
D6 King D4 and then you forc me to uh
move my king from
D6 King
D7 King D3 okay again King D6 King D4
again winning chances
if I move
here well you can try King C4 King C3
but um as long as black doesn't move to
this to D6 here um before the king moves
to
D4 black is
good so um the long short uh the long
story short A4 was a mistake instead of
playing A4 and losing that important
Pawn Tempo uh White should have started
just uh pushing the black king away um
just by using the king remember from
this end game don't lose those important
tempos like Pawn uh tempos because if
you lose that there is no way pawns
don't go back the only chance um to win
it it will be
a uh
just save those
tempos let's go back and let's see how
we could have won this
position okay this is the beginning uh
of the of this end
game instead of A4 why don't we play
Just King
C3 obviously Black's king is not going
to
um E4
because otherwise it will be um black
king has to block D5 just has to do
that let me show you what will
happen how do you
play and now the right
move what did the right move King D5
King D5 not D5 because D5 Los this King
D5 and then King E6 and um D5
D6 again be very careful and attentive
when even it seems to be winning that's
why King E4 is
impossible King E6 King goes
back what's our
move King C4 right away we're not going
to lose that opportunity and let um our
opponent just to go back to D5
if we have the chance to control D5 we
just go right after that what's our next
move D5 pay attention we haven't moved
any of the pawns
yet seems to be very easy but you know
what sometimes we make the mistakes in a
very simple positions very basic
positions that um we just we think it's
winning we don't stop for a second and
um think about that King D4 King D6
right what are the difference
now do you do you remember the previous
position with
A4 now look at this position and you uh
obviously you see the one difference the
pawn is still in
A3 this will be our winning move this is
how we're going to break through and go
to E5 and force Black's King to step
back
back why to
move any
suggestions which point do we move again
hard question in order to answer
calculate a little
bit I want to play A4 you want to play
A4 here let's see let's see how it works
when I play
A4 um I'll play G
six next
move
H3
okay H4 I play
H5 and then F okay let's return back do
I have any other options here how to oh
um save the
tempo obviously if I play H5 you meet me
with H4 right and then G6 um and
F3 okay any other moves that I can
have uh let you know what let me
try well if I if I play um King D7
You'll Play King E5 so I I I think your
uh idea with um A4 Works to so what
happened in the game
uh um white shoot I I mean this uh line
never happened in the game but this was
the winning line in the game she made
that mistake A4 so
H3 but I think A4 is winning too with H6
H4 we we had very similar line G6 F3 and
then A4 obviously we didn't so what did
we learn from this example okay going
back uh to the original position when
you have Point end game and you have an
extra Pawn try to promote your Pawn with
the help of the king as far as you can
and then use extra
tempos um that you you have left with
with your pawns just try to memorize
that that's a kind of the rule leave the
leave that weapon for later advance as
much as you can with the
pawn now we're getting uh to another
example another position that can easily
happen in the tournament games I it
happens many times in my practice um I'm
pretty sure that it happened to you guys
since I got a rook I'm I'm going to win
um the pawn is not too close to the
second rank that it's going to Queen so
I have plenty of temp temples to
win black played King to
F2 how would you play in this
position and why because you have
different
options can you win here can black make
a draw which piece do you want to um
bring
closer
raise your hands uh if you have any uh
idea you play with white let's say you
have 1 minute
left you take some seconds to think and
then you just have to make a move and
what is the price for the wrong
move you lose half point right it's draw
if you don't find the right
move King
D4 you would play King
D4 okay let's let's see King King D4
that can be an
option I have the only move I have to
rush with promoting my Pawn otherwise
he'll come
closer okay what's your next move and if
you uh offer a move try to support the
move with some line just don't don't um
offer just one single
move what's the next move
Rook f8 check Rook f8
check um I'm sorry this is this is not
me that's that wasn't
planned okay play
here I think King D3
Wasing so King D4 uh a little bit too
far yeah just obviously not our move
king3 is matter
okay King
D3 the same I play G3 I don't have any
other moves I have to
play
Just R
it can you uh advise me anything in this
position how would you
play with black
pieces try to think not only for
yourself but for the opponent because I
know we're trying to think about all for
white because we have a rook want to win
but your opponent dreams of a
draw we be very happy to make a draw in
this
position what are our options we have
three moves right not too many so which
move would you
prefer
King
E1 King E1
um I don't like King G2 at all because
it gives time for white to get closer
King G1 the same story so King E1 looks
kind of giv some chances maybe some
hopes for a draw so let's see if um if
it works how would you play uh with
white king is free but
black G2 the only move otherwise it's
lost
white uh Rook A8 what is the response
for Rook A8 Queen right and then white
will be dreaming of a draw so we have to
find the right move don't give the
chance for your opponent to be too
happy we have the only move
right Rook
G8 black King
F1
okay looks like a draw right because if
you bring the king then I'll Queen and
you'll have to sacrifice your Rook um if
you give me check I'll just go
back let's say If instead of King E1 so
this is George position this how easy um
you can make a draw if your opponent
doesn't follow the right
line oh excuse me that's the
mouse so if instead of
um King E1 I play King
G1 how do you win here and um do you
have
any chances to win actually at this
game king of three let's see
um how can I play here to King
F1 King G3 King G1
and Rook F2 let's see what is
interesting look at this give
check Rook F2
right okay I play
here what's
that and ta me
not that
easy we have to be again uh really
careful what we're doing
so play
here then um maybe instead of King G3
you have some other
idea do you think we have some chances
maybe try king um King get
too I'm sorry is it okay it was
see it's it's black Mo actually so
we maybe instead of King of3 King E2
here because King F3 seems to be a good
move right because you're provoking King
F1 King G3 but then uh by pretty easy
calculation uh it was a
stalemate what's your next
move
let's see move
here
okay and then King
F2 okay any any other chances for black
do you see any other strong moves that
we haven't reviewed King G1 going
back what's your move
well if you leave the rook and the King
here it will be draw so we have to move
somewhere King F3 they only move King f
one okay Rook A8 this is what I wanted
to hear from you guys yes Rook A8 if I
queen then Rook A1 Checkmate
um if I uh put the Knight here with a
check
can you win
here who knows so it's interesting it's
trans transposing do you see how fast
the end game can transpose you think you
were playing The Rook against the pawn
now you play Rook against the Knight
that's why you should keep in mind all
those main positions main um
structures what is the idea how um like
which structure
gives draw uh to
Black how do you place your knight and
the King do you know guys raise your
hand please I want to see the hands who
knows how to draw with the Knight and
with the king um against the king and
the Rook okay
one
two
three um okay it's pretty easy if you
play if you switch the
Knight and the King places it will be
draw because you'll be able to give the
checks to the king all the time so
imagine your knight on F1 and the King
on G1 that you'll be able to give a
check on um H2 then the king gets to G3
uh back Knight F1 so just in your mind
switch the king and the Knight that is
the drawish uh structure so don't forget
about that
um just switching the subject for a
second uh when you have a bishop and the
and the King how do you defend your
position is it different the structure
how how um you place your pieces to make
a draw bishop and the King how do you
place the pieces
guys we place we put King in the corner
right and then the bishop
the kind of covering the king from both
sides
uh there are two lines um how the king
can get attacked so that's why we place
the
bishop right next to the king but the
king is in the corner don't are confused
these two positions because when the
Knight and the
king the king is uh one square from the
uh Corner the Knight NE next to the king
but the bishop the king is in the the
corner and the bishop is next to the
king so just don't confuse because if
you confuse um it's lost so let's let's
play this my move I'll play
here how do you play with black what
what did this
R check from A1 so basically you have
just one
move Knight Knight E2 if you play King
to E2 what happen
happens pretty
easy do you see the
line Rook A1 um excuse
me Rook
A1 Knight moves to F3 then you give the
check from
A2 King G3 and you win the the Knight
right
easy so the only move that that we can
make here is Knight to E2
check why to
move okay and most
likely this this have very good chances
for uh
black to draw this game Let's return
back for a second look at this
position what is the other option that
we can use
here King is three right so we tried uh
one continuation King to G3 another one
king to E3 always try to if you have
time try to check both don't think that
if you calculated one it's just winning
maybe uh you missed something so that's
why if you if you have like minute just
look through the other one too
especially when you have just two um
um what happens if I play um Knight to
E2 real F just really easy just one move
Rook A1 um what happens if I play with
the King
here do we have chances to win
here how will you play
guys
who thinks that we can win here raise
your
hands one person uh do the rest think
that it's
draw we shouldn't say we don't know we
should have an opinion so who thinks
that it's winning you know there is no
third I'm not giving you third option uh
who thinks that it's winning okay I'll
think it's one person so the rest think
it's draw okay let's see uh since we
have just one person who thinks it's
winning let's check uh how how are you
going to
win okay so we have one person who said
that it's winning so um try to
win Rook j8 all right um I have a couple
moves here
let me try with this
one your next
move
G um excuse me Rook
G7 um let me try with the Knight
here do you think you can get with a
King to close
now King
E2 all right um check from
here see if I go
back
now what
happens G4 is the right move here
because I don't have any right any good
squares
but can move
here not that easy to win right so we
were talking about that structure
earlier right so the king uh one square
from the corner and then the um the
Knight next to the king not that
easy I let let's try different um ways
here so let's say if you're attack from
G3 then King goes back and uh what is
the beauty of this Knight on H3 the
knight from H3 controls uh F2 it doesn't
let the king move to F2 if the king
tries to get to F3 then um
the king will be checked from
G1 let's see if we have any other moves
so
um instead of Rook
G7 do we have any other options maybe we
can try something um different excuse me
play King F2 King
F2 play
here if King F3 then King uh then Knight
G1 so going
back
here and then obviously it's it's really
hard to um strengthen the POS uh
position so check King moved here let's
see if we give check what happens do we
have any chance here King to
G2 how do we move
here not really too many options to win
right because
so going back then King moves here and
then always have this Knight H3
trick uh let's return back because we
still have some positions to review
today and we haven't finished this Rook
end game so if if you're curious I mean
just um after the lecture when you go
home you can open this um Knight and the
King against the rook and the king and
just work on that so um King King F2 why
to play White to move what is the
winning move how do you win this
position Rook to A2 check Rook to a
let's see if it works by the way uh
kchoi played with
white um like excuse me how about how
about we play King to D3 first and then
when they run down the pawn then we'll
play a rook to A2 check King D3 yeah
here yeah and the difference is we we
might be able to hit him in a mating net
at the end okay that that can be a good
idea uh King to if I play King F1 what
what
happens we can get to uh the same
position like King A3 right G2 King F3
then if Queen then Rook A1 Checkmate we
already went through that so I I think
uh it doesn't make sense to to uh show
it on the board again uh then if the
um a little bit different if if it's the
night well maybe it makes sense to to
show look look what happens King F3 and
then the
Knight what are the difference with the
Knight here The Rook is an A2 so that
that is uh the difference so it may help
us just uh keep it in mind but guys the
main difference between us and kchoi
that he figured out the right move right
away so we're trying to choose well
maybe we should bring the uh the king
but such players as K they know right
away what they
do Rook f8 check nobody even said that
move you tried King D4 King D3 Rook A2
all kind of moves but nobody said Rook
f8 what do we do
next Rook G8 correct who said
that what is the difference now we bring
the king but we already won that Tempo
because the Rook is already on
G8 so the only move G3 because if the
king blocks on G3 obviously you bring
the king and um nothing good happens so
G3 easy Rook F
eight
King
two okay um I will play with black and
you should find the right most because
it's it's already winning so let me play
with black how can you
win Rook
G8 King F3 that's right King
F3
G2 now Rook
G8 but I have this
move king of two correct so don't don't
take the phone right away just calculate
the last moment okay let's go back uh
instead of this move I play
here King F3 correct G2
what the right move king of two okay
correct uh was seemed to be pretty easy
but um still needed some work to do this
is another sertic position that we
should
know so let's say many positions before
that before this one were pretty easy so
just if you if I gave you like five
minutes to concentrate you you would
probably find the right move um this one
you should know how to place your pieces
when you play with black and when you
play with white uh raise your hands who
think it's
draw again I I just got one person who
think who thinks that it's draw who
thinks it's winning everybody else
thinks it's winning
um it's thetically theoretically this is
a
draw uh practically you can you still
have the chance to win because to begin
with you have we have extra exchange
with white here and I would recommend
even if you think that well most likely
it's already a draw or you already know
that like after this lecture for
instance it happens to you in the game
and you know yeah it's a draw play till
the last chance because uh nobody gives
you the 100% um that your opponent knows
that it's draw and knows how to make the
draw so what you should memorize in this
type of positions the bishop should be
on the long diagonal always keep your
Bishop uh on this long diagonal the
pawns G6 H5 that's kind of Ideal
position uh with the pawn on H7 white
have uh more chances to
win if you play with white and your
opponent hasn't pushed the pawn to H5
try to prevent that by playing G3 to G4
okay that's another uh thing that you
should know if White's King uh trying to
get to
G5 where should you place your
Bishop on F6
correct some basic rules that you should
know now let's go over this end game and
you will see um the ideas how you can
try to get through this portrait and how
you should defend
that uh
H4 it's kind of you know this move why
is is it good because you you promote
the pawn you push the pawn closer to the
king and um anyway your ultimate idea
will be to play G4 because obviously
it's not if your opponent knows that he
has to prevent you to go to G5 it will
be pretty hard to win so you have to
play G G4 at some
point Bishop A1 um you keep the your
Bishop on this long
diagonal Rook to B4 what did the idea
wants to play G4 wants to uh break
through this Pawn chain and uh create
the weakness on G6 attack the weakness
and um finally get to the point where
white has a rook and the pawn on H4
against the bishop and the King trying
to win that King G7 we play G4 with
b um objectively it's pretty easy to
play with white with black you have much
more stress because you have to hold it
Rook takes King H6 if uh Bishop moves to
B2 what did the right move
here H5 so H5 is this right King H6 uh
the only right move King King H7 was a
possibility too but King H6 much better
uh because we want to get closer to
where to H4 Pawn right so the idea of
black is is pretty simple King H5 then
you attack the pawn uh with the bishop
and then uh the bishop against The Rook
probably your opponent will uh play that
another 50 moves to prove that that uh
draw but we already know how to make a
draw with the bishop and the King right
from the previous example we talked
about
that Rook G5 kind of trying to prevent
the king to get to H5 and get to the
point H4 uh Bishop
D4 King
F7 Bishop of two try to
bite uh not to allow white smoothly uh
take over in this position so attack
this Pawn H5 H4 don't don't let white uh
grab all the pawns here and uh keep this
H4 now what is
interesting uh here it's already draw
let's recall what are the main um the
main things that we have to memorize
from this position how to uh create this
Fortress keep the bishop on the long
diagonal try to place your Pawn on H5
and G six um when white king tries to
get to break through and get to a uh G
uh G5 from F4 uh control G5 with the
bishop uh from
F6 so but this position has many other
variations um you can see this position
with the point on H7 which makes uh
the um like whites play much easier
because the king doesn't have this H7
square and then you play G4 so you try
to um just box your opponent and um get
through that but still just try to
memorize at least just the main uh
things how to um hold this position when
you play with white and you see that
your opponent knows the structure well
try to play G4 uh trade these pawns and
attack G6 maybe you will uh be lucky and
just win that point on G6 and um keep
the point on
H2 uh so our lesson is almost over and
um I wanted to remind you again about in
the end games what what do we have to
what do we have to do how do we memorize
do we memorize like the moves no we
memorize the
ideas uh and you should hold always like
um pay attention of the ideas like in
this position the idea the bishop on the
LA diagonal at least memorize some
something in the pawn end games
returning back to this don't uh don't
rush with uh losing your Pawn
Tempo um in The Rook end games we
haven't reviewed one position I wanted
to show you um but in The Rook end games
they considered to be the most
complicated so just uh try to know
certain positions that you want to bring
your uh position just try to um know
what pieces you have to trade what
pieces you'll need which position you
know try to get to those
[Music]
[Applause]
positions